je passe ce soir chercher Natsu au Japon
et j'ai reçu ça ce matin c'est tout ce
dont j'ai besoin pour bien m'occuper de
lui donc on ouvre la vidéo sur ça c'est
très bien
le collier est énorme jamais reçu un
colis aussi gros voilà ceci était un
mensonge qui contient uniquement des
choses pour des animaux qui contient
aussi beaucoup de d'espaces vides oh là
là il y a plus rien dedans excellent je
sais pas si ce plan est bien je pense
qu'il est vraiment nul à chier et là je
réalise vraiment à ce moment précis que
je vais avoir un chien dans très peu de
temps première élément une serviette en
microfibre à quoi va-t-elle servir et
bien lorsque tu transportes ton chien
dans un sac il est mieux qu'il soit bien
déjà fait du bruit là donc on en prend
deux comme ça quand tu es en train
d'enlever une l'autre est disponible
excellent oh ça c'est des friandises
pour récompenser ton chien avec quelque
chose de bien
c'est quoi ça déjà oh c'est mignon c'est
une petite trousse de secours alors à ça
c'est de la bouffe la laisse
la première laisse de ma vie j'ai pris
une laisse où il y a pas de attends il y
a vraiment un youtubeur j'ai pris une
laisse basique tu vois 1m50 elle peut
faire pour le balader basiquement et
avec cette lettre qu'est-ce que j'ai un
petit harnais c'est beaucoup plus petit
tu vois je me suis trompé taille j'ai
vraiment pris le harnais pour les petits
caniches les Shiba je pense que ça
correspond à cette taille là j'ai
vraiment fait de la merde
et voilà un merveille au chat que je
peux désormais balader en laisse oh non
il n'aime pas le pauvre non oh il aime
pas du tout il est fâché ah oui
important un coup simple j'en ai pris un
taille immense pour que les chats
puissent se poser avec lui et qui se
fasse tous des bisous et qu'on soit une
belle famille bien soudée et très
heureuse là il est petit mais après il
sera il va grandir de ouf donc voilà
petite corde c'est un jouet finalement
bon ben voilà et là on a des croquettes
voilà pour pour chiot des croquettes de
bonne marque attention acheter bien de
la nourriture de qualité pour vos
animaux car c'est la source principale
de problèmes de santé il faut le savoir
tout ça pour vous dire qu'on a
maintenant tout ce qui nous faut sauf le
chien donc c'est un peu plus important à
tout de suite au Japon
[Musique]
et bien bonjour comment allez-vous moi
ça va extrêmement bien nous sommes
actuellement vendredi matin je suis
arrivé au Japon hier soir et la première
chose que je vais faire c'est aller voir
Natsu on attend ça depuis maintenant
trois semaines on va partir maintenant
on va le rejoindre et on va tout chialer
parce qu'on va être aimé c'est parti
nous nous approchons actuellement de
l'endroit où natsu se trouve j'ai le
cœur qui bat vite je suis très ému
[Musique]
comment tu vas mon pote tu as grandi tu
es un grand bonhomme
tu as grandi
mon dieu
c'est nouveau ok ça va mon pote 3
semaines 3 semaines
je pense que tu m'as reconnu je sais pas
mais ah tu détruit mon pull ça marche
bon les amis Natsu a grandi de malade
regardez ça regardez-moi ce grand
bonhomme il m'a reconnu je suis trop
content il m'a fait une fête de malade
dès qu'un chien s'approche de moi il
veut le bouffer parce qu'il est jaloux
je montre comment ça va être avec les
chats là-bas il aime pas la Baba je vais
me raser j'ai compris je vais me rase il
est trop heureux il a vraiment grandi je
pense qu'il fait deux fois la taille de
quand je l'avais vu la dernière fois on
va sortir on va faire une balade mon
chien oui
ça c'est pas un chien heureux ça qui
montre le bidon non la semaine assez en
paix tu vas arrêter de tout démolir tu
vas attendre d'être à la maison pour
tout démolir tu vas me racheter des
Adidas après par contre ça je te le dis
oh il vous dit bonjour tu es bien
là-dessus tu es déjà un très bon
youtubeur
laisse-moi ma caméra tu dois me racheter
de l'adidas et une caméra déjà allez on
va se balader c'est parti mon grand
allons nous balader dans ma ville
préférée
[Musique]
une petite bosse mon pote j'ai peur ce
qui se blesse sur un papa Gaga ça va mon
petit Natsu ça va il écoute bien j'ai lu
un peu des techniques quand ils font
chier on laisse qu'il faut faire et tout
je me souviens de rien mais j'ai lu on
est sur un poupe
et attention la première merde de chien
je vais être de ma vie et on y va
problème c'est qu'il y a pas de poubelle
à Tokyo donc tu es obligé de le mettre
dans ton sac à dos à toi bah c'était la
première balade avec natweet j'espère
qu'elle vous aura plu il y en aura
d'autres je pense qu'à un moment on ira
kamakoula dans dans le sable j'ai trop
hâte de des prochaines balades puis
voilà j'espère que cette première vous a
plu je sais pas si je vais refiler
aujourd'hui je vais profiter un maximum
avec lui auquel cas je vous fais plein
de bisous je vous dis à très vite au
revoir
[Musique]
et bien bonjour les amis il fait beau
nous sortons de deux jours de pluie
Natsu n'a pas pu sortir et là il est
complètement excité parce qu'il va
pouvoir aller au parc à chien du parc
Yoyogi un enclos avec des chiens de sa
taille enfin j'espère qu'il y aura des
chiens parce que on est lundi après-midi
j'espère qu'il y a déjà qui travaille
pas il va s'éclater gambader s'amuser
[Musique]
tu vois ton chien heureux comme jamais
et je découvre un peu la sensation que
les gens à sortir avec leur chien être
content parce qu'il voit leur chien
heureux je ressens un peu pareil après
j'avoue jusqu'à tout moment de faire un
arrêt cardiaque parce que je cours à
côté lui comme un con
c'était un petit caca n'oublie pas mon
grand faut que je fasse redescendre
parce qu'il va prendre la grosse tête
comme son maître après il a fait un
terrier mon gars il a gratté mais de ouf
ici là ça sent mon chien il trouve les
trésors mon gars bon les amis c'est la
fin de la balade ça fait 1h30 2h à peu
près qu'on est là c'est bien dépensé
j'ai acheté un sac et une boutique en
face du parc c'est un sac à dos et je
parle de balader avec moi grâce à ça
c'est la première fois qu'on le met dans
attention voyons voir comment il le
prend
oh là là les amis je suis le mec le plus
Gaga du monde attention
[Musique]
on est bien ou pas imagine moi sur le
scout comme ça direction mon bureau pour
tourner est-ce que même il kiffe un peu
il se dit [ __ ] je me balade mais sans
faire d'efforts physiques c'est bien ça
c'est aussi le début de l'obésité
attention Natsu tu dis à demain à demain
[Musique]
bonsoir chers amis on est sur une petite
mine pourquoi on est sur une petite mine
parce qu'hier on s'en est pris une mine
oh là là comment sur la bouffer
aujourd'hui il y a ce soir c'était
Halloween à Tokyo je l'ai fêté à Shibuya
au milieu de 1 milliard de japonais j'ai
vu des mecs arrivés dans des castunes en
mode Tokyo Drift et en fait ils étaient
hyper sympa tellement sympa qu'ils nous
ont fait faire un tour
le problème c'est que mon conducteur
parlait pas un mot d'anglais donc quand
je vais filmais il savait pas trop
comment réagir le pauvre allez gatant
j'ai aussi croisé des gens qui étaient
chargés de ramasser les poubelles des
éboueurs finalement qui étaient déguisé
en Mario et Luigi
aujourd'hui on est où on est à Kamakura
il y a pas mal de temps ici il y a aussi
the great Bouddha une statue de Bouddha
fait 13 mètres de haut et 121 tonnes
c'est juste incroyable la plage est à
seulement 300 mètres d'ici donc on va
clairement y aller il faut que je prenne
un café entre temps [ __ ] je suis
rentré très tard hier d'Halloween mais
c'est incroyable
c'est génial on arrive sur la plage il y
a une pancarte qui t'avertit des
tsunamis en cas de tremblement de terre
attention au tsunami qui va provoquer il
te disent qu'en gros même s'il y a pas
d'alarme il peut y avoir un tsunami plus
ou moins gros qui arrive donc faut être
attentif et remarquer s'il y a des
choses étranges ça c'est flippant alors
attention attends je te retire ça tu es
prêt à courir tu es libre
[Musique]
alors j'ai une frayeur nulle de mettre
nul j'ai peur qu'un de ces énormes
oiseaux le shop et s'envole avec
là-dessus c'est fait des potes sur la
plage ça c'est beau ça
[Musique]
demain dernier jour au Japon avant le
retour le but ça va être qui se dépense
un max pour que dans l'avion il dorme le
plus possible je suis anxieux mais pas
trop parce qu'il est très cool et très
calme je sais au moins qu'il fera pas
chier les autres de passager du Val
comment va-t-il réagir face au chat de
la maison c'est la grosse question ah je
suis mort
[Musique]
ça y est il est chez moi bon je vais pas
vous mentir j'ai pas filmé l'arrivée
dans l'appartement parce que après 12
heures de vol j'étais un peu mort mais
en tout cas dans l'avion ça s'est trop
bien passé Natsu n'a pas hurlé une fois
il a été le chien le plus gentil en
arrivant à l'appartement en fait les
chats se sont juste planqués j'interdis
à Natsu l'accès à la chambre donc le
chat se réfugier dedans après ils ont
pas l'air d'avoir peur plus que ça en
vrai mais bon la climatation va mettre
plusieurs jours c'est normal est-ce que
vous avez remarqué mon petit kimono
stylet hein
apparemment voilà ça fait bizarre de
l'avoir à la maison je réalise toujours
pas et je suis un peu parano j'ai
toujours l'impression qu'il s'ennuie ou
qu'il est triste parce qu'il est plus au
Japon ou que alors qu'en vrai je pense
qu'il s'en fout mais je je sais pas j'ai
trop peur pour lui je l'aime tellement
je suis vraiment Gaga de ce chien c'est
très très grave il faudrait un numéro
d'aide pour les gens trop Gaga de leurs
animaux tu as de la pisse sur la patte
je sens c'est humide c'est bien la piste
alors il pisse là dessus à la maison
quoi qu'il puisse par terre et mon chien
il est bien éduqué ok je lui dis à très
vite et à bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo je vous aime là-dessous vous aime
alors aimez-vous vous-même ce pire ou
trop
[Musique]